reste à ta place reste à ta place est le
titre d'un livre signé sébastien le fol
directeur de la rédaction du point qui
scrute ce mal français le mépris de
classe c'est un facteur d'immobilisme
alors évidemment ça peut être aussi un
moteur pour ceux qui le subissent on va
en débattre dans un instant mais d'abord
d'abord le portrait d'un jeune homme qui
se bat pour aider les créateurs
d'entreprise en banlieue et en zone
rurale il s'appelle moussa camara c'est
le fondateur dé déterminer flora sauvage
moussa camara est parti de rien n'est à
cergy pontoise une fois son bac pro
logistique en poche il crée à 21 ans son
entreprise de sous traitance
d'opérateurs télécoms laventure va durer
cinq ans avant de se solder par un échec
ni té boîte à l'âge de 20 ans où vous
n'avez pas forcément de référence
d'entrepreneurs autour de vous ou vous
avez des difficultés pour comprendre
comment marche l'administration d'une
entreprise finalement en fait ma boîte
j'aurais pu la transformer créer des
centaines d'emplois mais finalement j'ai
pas réussi à passer ce cap là parce que
j'étais trop limité et j'étais seule on
va parler de ton projet issu d'une
famille modeste de huit enfants moussa
camara aurait aimé être soutenu à
l'époque et un plafond de verre ça c'est
des réelles il faut dire la réalité des
choses après sur la question si on veut
on peut moi je n'y crois pas en fait et
cette phrase ça veut dire que ceux qui
ne réussissent pas ceux qui aujourd'hui
malheureusement n'ont pas la chance de
risque c'est qu'ils veulent pas s'en
sortir c'est faux nous on n'a pas cette
capacité donc il faut amorcer des des
petites solutions qui vont permettre
déjà à certains de lever la tête de
l'eau afin d'inciter les jeunes issus
des quartiers prioritaires à monter leur
entreprise
il crée une association qu'il intitule
et déterminer toute la jeunesse et et
qui a dans nos quartiers dans nos villes
dans les territoires urbains dans nos
campagnes ils ont cette volonté de s'en
sortir ils ont cette énergie cette gnac
maintenant il faut créer des passerelles
faut donner des outils il faut favoriser
tout ça parce que deux matchs intimement
convaincu que grâce au développement
économique grâce aussi à
l'inclusion économique qu'on va réussir
à tirer une réussite sociale de toutes
les populations en six ans l'association
les déterminées à former plus de 400
personnes comme radouane issus de mantes
la jolie
il a bénéficié de ce programme
d'accompagnement gratuits pour monter sa
boîte fut le fondateur de vente il est
mon petit laisse la vente de les frères
en circuit court sous forme de consignes
lui à des moyens de transport
écologiques et tout ça pour permettre
aux producteurs fermiers d'être rémunéré
à un meilleur prix moi j'avais
simplement l'idée mais par contre
j'avais j'avais besoin d'un cadre et
donc les déterminer pendant six mois et
moins apporté ce cadre à trouver un
financement se constitue un réseau
autant de démarches qui n'était pas si
facile pour as douanes il ya des
personnes qui sont nés avec un budget
avec une famille qui va qui vont leur
donner les contacter en passant trois
coups de fil il remontait une boîte avec
un capital important nous de ce côté là
on n'a pas cette chance là peut-être
qu'à l'avenir en fait avec ce type
d'associations et des personnes
aspirante on aura des contacts comme ça
et on pourra aider d'autres d'autres
jeunes pousses qui voudront entreprendre
depuis sa création plus de la moitié des
participants à ce programme ont créé
leur propre entreprise
pour débattre des ravages du mépris à la
française jacques sébastien le fol
bonjour un bon jour vous publiez donc
reste à ta place c'est chez albin michel
c'est évidemment votre livre qui nous a
donné envie de monter ce débat à vos
côtés annabelle allouche bonjour je
viens venu vous êtes maître de
conférences en sociologie à l'université
de picardie jules verne vous publiez
mérite c'est aux éditions alamo âmes
bruno cautrès bonjour je recherche au
cnrs et au cevipof
vous avez notamment corriger cette
grande antenne enquête intitulée la
france en morceaux enquête qui scrute
analyse nos fracture territoriale est
ici accueil pas toujours toujours à mes
côtés peut-être une petite réaction à ce
à ce reportage pour commencer la france
dont parle moussa camara est ce que vous
diriez bruno cautrès que c'est la france
des lisiers on a beaucoup parlé de cette
france là oui clairement c'est vrai que
l'un des enjeux aujourd'hui très
important pour le pôle pays c'est
effectivement cette question d'aller
trouver les nouveaux talents de demain
les nouveaux talents de la société
française il ya beaucoup d'acteurs de la
société civile il ya beaucoup d'acteurs
dans les collectivités locales aussi
dans les régions qui oeuvrent pour cette
belle cause qui est d'aller trouver
l'initiative d'aller aider des porteurs
de projets effectivement pour aider
notamment non seulement désenclavement
sociologique mais territoriale aussi de
la société française donc cette histoire
est effectivement très illustrative de
toute une myriade de réalités qui
existent au niveau des au niveau des
régions au niveau des territoires qui
passe très souvent sous le radar de
l'actualité politique et de l'actualité
et des institutions
sous le radar aussi des politiques eux
mêmes des aides et
voilà des médias alors même qu'à à la
fois il ya un vivier qui est très
important il ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup d'initiatives et je pense qu'un
vrai vrai vrai vrai thème
particulièrement pour les prochaines
échéances électorales de ressources et
les filières du mérite du talent notre
société française souvent qu'on va
employer beaucoup par demerit talent
mépris ça va animer notre débat je vous
entends d'un abbé la louche là dessus on
se prive de milliers de de talent qui
qui renonce parce qu'ils n'ont pas
trouvé un moussa camara pour leur donner
le petit le petit coup de pouce c'est
vrai mais en même temps ce qui
m'impressionne toujours c'est à quel
point tu crois au mérite le mérite ne
fonctionne pas quand il est à l'école en
tout cas pour certaines personnes ça ne
fonctionne pas clairement on voit le
taux de classes populaires dans les
grandes écoles dans certaines grandes
écoles et pourtant on croit au mérite on
se revendique du mérite notre identité
sociale et structurée sur la base du
mérite et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant en fait ont continué à se
revendiquer du mérite même si on sait
sociologiquement que la méritocratie ne
fonctionne pas oui donc c'est presque
une croyance on
sébastien le fol ce reste à ta place
vous l'avez peut-être il faut
personnaliser un peu vous l'avez d'abord
vécu comme une blessure personnelle oui
le point de départ de ce livre et les
personnels j'ai entendu quand j'étais
adolescent une phrase qui m'a évidemment
bouleversé dans la bouche d'un cousin de
mon pea côté conducteur de travaux qui
est mon permis je voulais faire
journalistes étaient assez décidé assez
tôt et le a dit mais ce n'est pas un
métier fait pour des gens comme nous il
faut que tu lui sans cette idée de la
tête et c'est vrai que cette phase
d'abord ma paralysé et ensuite elle m'a
bigrement motivé j'évolue défier j'ai
voulu aller contre ce qui semble être
une fatalité est dictée par ce membre de
ma famille donc oui c'est daoud et par
une blessure personnelle et sanaa un
inventaire bientôt la cinquantaine voire
ce que j'ai fait de cette phrase ce qui
était la part de vérité dans cette
phrase mais aussi la part de fiction
mais surtout ce qui est intéressant
c'est un moteur qui s'alimentent
éternellement ou presque c'est à dire
que est-ce que la blessure qui est
adolescente elle réapparaît comme ça de
temps en temps on attend sans doute un
mois j'ai les miens c'est non et donc
que et donc quand on doute peut-être que
cette blessure personnelle parce que se
trouve un petit peu quand on conquérir
une place pour lequel visiblement on
n'était pas fait c'est ce que j'avais
compris c'est vrai qu'on ressent très
longtemps je crois jusqu'à la fin de sa
vie un certain sentiment d'imposture on
attribue très peu d'ailleurs à son
propre mérite sans en faire une religion
ce qui nous arrive mais au contraire on
la tribu à la chance à à une main tendue
et d'ailleurs j'ai ce sentiment là je
les ai rencontrés chez beaucoup des
personnalités que j'ai interrogées pour
ce livre ousmane camara ont fait partie
je sais c'est ce qui m'a nous a mis sur
la piste intéressé chez lui parce que
lui il a il a choisi une autre voie il
est l'incarnation de cette phrase que
emmanuel macron avait prononcé un jour
il y aujourd'hui pour certains jeunes en
france il est plus facile de trouver un
client qu'un job et moussa camara ses
illustrations de ça c'est comment voilà
que quand on n'a pas eu un mérite
reconnu par la filière scolaire comment
on construit des choses lui il a cru
très tôt à l'entrepreneuriat l'a voulu
et le chef d'entreprise et c'est ce
qu'il a dit cette passion là qu'il a
décidé de faire parts alors on va
reparler des personnalités que vous avez
rencontrées pour pour ce livre mais le
constat le plus important et on va en
débattre c'est l'immobilisme pour vous
pourquoi quand vous le lien entre ce
mépris qu'ils diffusent un peu partout
et l'immobilisme le seul le mépris c'est
un sentiment très partagés moi j'ai
beaucoup méprisé je le confesse dans ce
livre d'ailleurs je ne m'en cache pas
le plus m'arrivait d'être méprisé mais
on peut très bien s'en sortir je
pourrais le mépris c'est quelque chose
est institutionnalisé en france il est
dans l' architecture même de notre
organisation sociale à la fois hérité de
l'ancien régime je pense que la
révolution française n'a pas été terminé
nous sommes encore largement une société
de cour de connivence et le privilège
avec des statuts un rang à tenir donc il
y à une cascade de mépris comme disait
un historien qui tombe de rang en rend
encore dans la société française oblige
le même os y avait bien des crises à il
ya le froissement permanente d'amour
propre au sein même de deux catégories
sociales de profession oui même dans une
catégorie qui peut en mépriser notre
mais au sein même de cette catégorie
voire du mépris parce qu'on a on a
absolument un rang à tenir et on voit
tout ce qui menace euros ou 7 positions
il va avec avec une certaine
condescendance souvent oui on veut
préserver ce ce ce rang et c'est
d'autant plus vils à ce moment où
effectivement il ya une craie dre crise
de la reconnaissance je pense dans notre
société et donc il ya une crispation
autour de ces questions là beaucoup plus
forte c'est ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous écrivez que le mépris sera sans
doute un des thèmes centraux de la
présidentielle 2022 un des enjeux pour
les candidats et vous êtes plusieurs à
travailler sur ce sujet je pense
notamment aux travaux de cynthia fleury
qui est philosophe sociologue aussi
pierre rosanvallon qui la sort un livre
sur les épreuves
comprendre mieux les français et tous
parlent vous parler mais du mépris du
ressentiment c'était vraiment c'est une
donnée sociale qui est fondamental
aujourd'hui pour comprendre où nous en
sommes leurs sentiments et leurs
sentiments je crois que c'est jacques
attali qui en parle le mieux à mon goût
dans votre ville il dit la revanche
sociale leurs sentiments ça peut
conduire au meilleur comme au pire au
meilleur comme par exemple avec
bérégovoy et au pire par exemple avec
doriot et c'est ce qui explique les
spécialistes c'est que le fascisme est
la conséquence quand on regarde
l'histoire immédiate à qui nous
précèdent du ressentiment et du mépris
ça c est qui est ressenti de façon
globale dans la population pourrait dans
votre sang j'ai été frappée d'écouter la
deux discours de candidat à la
présidentiel xavier bertrand et anne
hidalgo qui tous les deux ont
effectivement posé cette question du
mépris j'étais encore très net chez anne
hidalgo dimanche dernier et là on va on
va écouter je suis sûr qu'en régie vous
êtes prêts à me suivre un extrait
justement de ce discours entrée en
campagne à nidal gones une campagne
présidentielle c'est la rencontre entre
un candidat une candidate et le peuple
et il faut un peu se dévoile et
peut-être qu'elle l'a fait à contrecoeur
anne hidalgo mais en tout cas elle a
parlé de son histoire personnelle en
écoute
moi une femme française née en espagne
arrivé dans notre pays à l'âge de 2 ans
élevé à lyon dans un quartier et
attachant un quartier populaire et
aujourd'hui sur ce port de rouen je
pense à mon père qui fut ouvriers sur le
chantier naval de cadix je pense aussi à
ma mère couturière
ils ont fait le choix de la france pour
offrir une éducation et un avenir un
masseur et à moi je veux que tous les
enfants de france aient la même chance
que celle qui m'a été donnée je suis
candidate pour offrir un avenir à nos
enfants à tous nos enfants
sébastien le fol elle est où vous avez
rencontré anne hidalgo pour ce livre
elle l'a subie le mépris sous quelle
forme alors c'est un souvenir
d'humiliation très fort qu'elle est
ressentie
dans la bouche d'un professeur d'auxerre
de maths je me sentirai elle a rendez
vous avec son père et
s'interroge son père sur les études
qu'elle doit faire ensuite après le bac
et ce professeur lui dit mais vous savez
je vous déconseille les études
supérieures va ça va l'éloigner
socialement et surtout secrétaire de
direction ce serait déjà très très bien
donc elles en parlent évidemment encore
c'est une année marquée au fer rouge
encore par sept la cette expression
flagrante de mépris mais c'est méprisant
pour les secrétaires de direction c'est
d'abord méprisant pour les secrétaires
de direction des dahus puis c'est une
assignation à résidence une terrible
alors je voudrais qu'on puisse
maintenant élargir un petit peu le débat
vous avez commencé à le faire laëtitia
mais sur ce que ça dit de la société
française évidemment et peut-être des
épisodes qu'on a vécu pendant ce mandat
de d'emmanuel macron là bruno cautrès au
cevipof vous sondez régulièrement les
les français qu'est ce qu'ils disent
tiens de cette notion de deux mérites de
mépris ils disent que la méritocratie à
la française est sacrément en crise et
que tous les indicateurs que nous
développons dans nos enquêtes sur est ce
que ça fonctionne est ce que au fond
quand on joue le jeu quand on applique
les règles du jeu est ce qu on en est
rétribué le regard que portent les
français est très largement non alors
c'est vrai que la méritocratie semble
bloquée semble en panne en france et
c'est vrai que par ailleurs on le sait
le sentiment de mépris est très très
très important nous avons conduit une
expérience récemment dans une de nos
enquêtes le baromètre de la confiance
politique
du cevipof on a proposé aux personnes
interrogées 2000 français une liste de
cinq noms connotée positivement et une
liste de cinq mots connoté négativement
et on leur a demandé quels sont les
premiers mots parmi ceux là qui
décrivent la manière dans la société
française vous traitent le premier s'est
mépris
le deuxième c'est un justice arrive en
3ème égalité et tout de suite derrière
des mots qui sont négatifs on a été nous
mêmes surpris de voir le sentiment de
mépris je rejoins ce qui a été dit tout
à l'heure le regard que portent les
français non seulement c'est que la
france est une société inégalitaire
injuste
mais aussi qui traite mal les gens là
problème de la considération de la
dignité était tout à fait central dans
la crise des gilets jaunes mon mon
collègue du cevipof samuel hayat a
écrite de ce point de vue là un très
beau très beau texte qui était sur la
dimension d'économie morale qui était à
travers la crise des religieuses dr c
c'est ce sentiment au fond de ne plus
être considéré et d'être renvoyé en
permanence effectivement soit des échecs
personnels data pas assez travaillé à
l'école donc t'as pas le passeport clés
de la société française le diplôme est
enfin lorsqu'on a étudié cette grande
enquête sur le baromètre des détails toi
la france en morceaux on a fait une
cartographie par géographique mais
sociologique aussi des français on a 25
% des personnes qu'on a interrogés qu'on
peut appeler des sortes des signes et
sert des gens qui disent bah moi
j'aimerais bouger j'aimerais m'en sortir
je voudrais bougé et je voudrais vivre
mieux mais je peux pas assez trop cher
c'est trop compliqué déménager s'est
soldée des factures sans ouvrir de
nouvelles j'y arrive pas et on avait à
l'extrême opposé un groupe de 20 % de
gens que nous avons appelé les
affranchis ceux qui au contraire disent
pas de soucis etc et puis on voyait
aussi une différence entre les assigner
puis les gens qui par contre on honnart
en enracinement local qui n'ont pas
d'aspirations à la mobilité qui tourne
mais moi je suis au pays je suis bien
j'ai pas envie de la société d'emmanuel
macron kindy faut traverser la rue faut
se bouger je suis bien dans mon temps
mon coin tout seul et donc on veut
parler
et donc on veut une société française je
rejoins ce qui a été dit ou la question
de la place la question du mérite la
question de ce sentiment de mépris est
très important annabelle a eu ce
sentiment
il a alimenté
les colères de ces dernières années des
gilet jaune aux antilles vagues sont
aujourd'hui oui absolument mais en
écoutant anne hidalgo ce qui me saute
aux yeux c'est vraiment la saturation
dans l'espace public de cette rhétorique
méritocratique pas ce que dit anne
hidalgo elle se définit par rapport aux
mérites finalement aldi mains voila je
suis jeune fille d'immigrés qui a réussi
à atteindre une position sociale et une
position politique
nationale de premier rang de la mairie
de paris et je veux qu'on me définissent
par rapport à mon mérite et c'est
exactement ça à la fois les français
cherchent à ce qu'on reconnaisse leur
mérite et en même temps ce qu'ils disent
et les institutions en particulier
l'institution scolaire n'est pas en
mesure de reconnaître mon mérite donc il
ya vraiment ce double niveau d'où le
mouvement à la fois je crois au mérite
je voudrais qu'on reconnaît son mérite
mais en même temps je sais que les
institutions ne le reconnaissent pas en
particulier d'institutions scolaires et
je pense que ce sentiment de mépris non
par bruno cautrès et et stéphane le foll
et se situe là en fait dans cette
signature entre la croyance dans le
mérite et le
bout du coriace et les spurs a dit c'est
une religion vous dit vraiment ça c'est
une croyance soit une réalité c'est une
croyance et une rhétorique à laquelle on
croit
est inscrite dans l'esprit même de la
république française un codé par les
construite sur cette valeur la lamelle
méritocratie c'est voilà l'idée qu'on va
par l'éducation vous arrachez
après c'est je trouve
c'est pas mergia le procès du mérite qui
est fait c'est le monopole de mérite
qu'aujourd'hui série de sorges certains
une partie de la population on le voit
la démocratisation de l'enseignement
supérieur dans les années 60 a amené une
nouvelle génération nouvelle classe
surdiplômés 1 qui aujourd'hui
effectivement revendique un peu le
monopole du mérite c'est une vision du
mérite extrêmement cognitive très
scolaire c'est-à-dire que et méritant
celui qui use celle qui très jeune a été
réussie d'aider des grands concours et
ceux qui ne sont pas passés par là
effectivement qui ont qui veulent voir
et valoriser d'autres qualités ne se
sentent pas reconnus dans ce système là
et qui équipe malgré tout les exclus
parce que il est porteur d'un système de
valeurs qui dont ils se sentent dans
lequel ils se sentent méprisés alors je
repose la question sur les mouvements
les mouvements de colère peut-être à
vous et aux contres scc vous faites le
lien très clairement entre ce qu'on
décrit là depuis quelques minutes et et
cette tension permanente consent dans la
société française oui très clairement
très clairement il ya quelque chose qui
unit effectivement différente secousses
qu'ont connu la canule à la société
française au cours des des 20 ou 30
dernières années effectivement à cette
grande question la question de l'école
la question de l'intégration de
l'inclusion sociale à travers l'école
est une véritable plaque tectonique la
société française et c'est vrai que si
on suit ensuite les travaux des
spécialistes
l'économie de la confiance ils disent
que tout se joue à l'école au fond de
l'école et la première le premier espace
public dans lequel le jeune citoyen va
rencontrer la réalité du jugement des
autres de l'inégalité le classement la
hiérarchie
comme comme enseignant à l'université à
sciences po ssible par exemple j'ai j'ai
toujours un vrai point d'interrogation
que je doive continuer à noter des
élèves qui sont à bac +5 en me disant
mais il faut continuer à noter des gens
que nous avons sélectionnés partout que
nous avons noté depuis leur plus jeune
âge il arrive à bac +5 continuer à les
classer à les noter il ya quelque chose
qui effectivement de ce point de vue là
y est en travers de sociétés françaises
et fois l'alternative je pense que
l'alternative c'est sans aucun doute
déjà de repenser les dispositifs
d'enseignement avec quelque chose qu'ils
misent davantage sur la prise
d'initiative de de l'élève aussi je suis
pas un spécialiste de pédagogie mais il
me semble quand même que il ya là un
travers de la société française qui n'a
su flou pas à travers les premières
étapes dans l'école la confiance en soi
la confiance dans les autres et qui va
apprendre à cultiver l'échec voilà qui
bat le souvenir l'échec est une chance
que l'échec est une chance et qui tout
de suite fait rencontrer le jeune
citoyen à travers cette question du la
hiérarchie du classement par rapport à
imposer des tests sortir du modèle
unique de réussite sociale parce que
finalement on comprend qu'il ya une
vision monolithique de la réussite
sociale qui est sur la forme ascendante
pourquoi il faudrait toujours monté avec
cet ascenseur social pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas rester à son étage et être
tout autant considérer et dont on
pourrait apprécier les qualités de
chacun à chaque étage pourquoi faut-il
toujours monter absolument c'est une
revendication des gels et jaune toute
façon alléger les jeunes n'ont pas de
revendications éducative au sens strict
du terme une demande pas par exemple des
places à l'université mais heureux ils
demandent une reconnaissance de leur
dignité de travailleurs et demandent une
reconnaissance
une égalité fiscale et demandent une
reconnaissance de leurs mérites in fine
est donc effectivement le problème c'est
véritablement que le mérite est
exclusivement dans l'espace public a un
mérite scolaire au sens le plus réduit
du terme c'est-à-dire un mérite de
grandes écoles disons le clairement elle
est ici à vous il ya une phrase qui a
marqué le mandat des manuels macron il y
en a eu plusieurs médailles c'est le
premier de cordée quand comment vous
l'analysez comment vous la relier à au
débat qu'on a quand je pense qu'elle
illustre la faillite totale d' emmanuel
macron dans son quinquennat a parlé à
tendre la main à établir le dialogue
avec cette france dit invisible cette
france qui se sent méprisée et qui ne se
sent pas dont on a enlevé la dignité
emmanuel macron il me semble est
incapable de le faire edouard philippe a
été incapable de le faire alors ils sont
bons dans les constats mais quand
emmanuel macron parle on est en octobre
2017 c'est sa première interview télé il
parle des premiers de cordée d'accord il
dit si on commence à acheter des
cailloux sur les premiers de cordée
c'est toute la corde et qui dégringole
alors après il va faire des explications
de texte en disant mais vous n'avez rien
compris alors il l'a fait au cours de la
conférence justement qui suit la crise
des gilets jaunes en dix ans mais je
parlais de l'accord par qu'elle unit les
français c'est la nation si le ciment de
la nation ensuite il nous le dit mais
dans une cordée il n'y a pas que les
premiers il est aussi ce qui assure dont
il a fait vraiment dès la sortie des
rames en tout cas ce qu'on a compris
c'est qu'il s'adressait aux premiers de
cordée et c'est un peu le défaut d'
emmanuel macron il est bon quand il
parle patron on le comprend quand il
leur dit attention tenez bien votre
corde mais il ne parle pas à ceux qui
sont en bas et en termes quand même en
marqueur on va dire politique de son
quinquennat il a quand même supprimer
les selfs dans le même temps en arrivant
à l'elysée et ça ça reste un marqueur
les mairies social de son quinquennat
rose différentes je pense que son
programme de 2010 est était un programme
sur qui traitait de cette question là
c'est à dire que c'est un projet un
programme ouvertement comme libérale qui
voulait rompre avec les statuts la
société de rente qui est quand même une
une des sources quand même de ce mépris
en france et que la société bloquée
aussi parce que le marché du travail est
quand même aujourd'hui par avec notre
droit du travail conçu pour les pour les
insiders les gens qui sont en place qui
ont déjà des contrats à durée
indéterminée et ce système là c'est une
machine de guerre contre les nouveaux
entrants
ceux qui veulent réussir donc il avait
un programme qui allait dans ce sens et
le paradoxe est qu effectivement
quelques années après à la veille d'une
élection présidentielle
il est tout en lui attente aujourd'hui
un procès en mépris alors justement on
va faire le bilan du mandat d' emmanuel
macron en matière de lutte contre les
inégalités avec steve au jourdain qui
qui nous rejoint pour une nouvelle
chronique quel bilan pour le président
de la république c'est le thème de votre
coup thomas l'égalité des chances est
une priorité c'est pas moi qui lien
c'est emmanuel macron c'était emmanuel
macron c'était il ya un an en septembre
c'était au panthéon pour les 150 ans de
la troisième république écoutez le
l'égalité des chances n'est pas encore
effective aujourd'hui dans notre
république
c'est pourquoi elle est plus que jamais
une priorité de ce quinquennat nous
irons plus loin
plus fort dans les semaines à venir pour
que la promesse républicaine soient
tenus dans le concret des vies qu'est ce
qui a été fait depuis trop peu en tout
cas selon les parlementaires alors
rappelons peut-être quelques mesures
phares qui ont été poussés par
l'exécutif il ya eu le dédoublement des
classes de cp et de ce1 en éducation
prioritaire l'objectif est bien c'est
que 100% des élèves maîtrisent les
enseignements fondamentaux sortir de
l'école primaire autre mesure phare
thomas du gouvernement la création d'une
plate forme nationale en ligne de
signalement des discriminations et puis
on a pas mal parlé en ces derniers mois
le service national universel s est nu
et 15 mille jeunes y ont participé cet
été on rappelle peut-être un peu le
principe des jeunes de 15 à 17 ans un
séjour tous ensemble en dehors de leur
département d'origine objectif
transmettre un socle républicain à notre
jeunesse permettre le brassage social
autre dispositif il s'appelle un jeune
un mentor il s'agit d'un accompagnement
à l'enseignement professionnel
quelques heures par mois un mentor
accompagner un jeune souvent issu d'un
milieu modeste il aide à s'orienter à
l'école ou encore au boulot et puis
enfin dernier dispositif mis en place
thomas par le gouvernement la boussole
des aides c'est un simulateur dead en
ligne simulateur simplifiée qui permet
par exemple aux jeunes de connaître
quels sont les dispositifs des aides
auxquelles ils sont éligibles alors tout
ça c'est très bien selon les
parlementaires mais ça ne suffit pas le
compte n'y est clairement pas ici au
sénat une mission d'information a été
lancée en février dernier à l'initiative
des socialistes elle doit rendre ses
conclusions la semaine prochaine on
suivra sa toque thomas on est sur le
coup merci beaucoup merci jourdain pour
ce focus sur le bilan inégalités du
président de la république
sébastien le fol je voudrais revenir un
peu aux personnalités que vous avez
l'interrogé pour pour ce livre de
nicolas sarkozy à fabrice luchini en
passant par anne hidalgo on en a parlé
bernard tapie
il forme la voilà partie émergée de
l'iceberg c'est ce qu'ils ont comme vous
trouvez un moteur quoi survécu au mépris
ils ont un point commun c'est qu'ils ont
briser le plafond de verre autour du
plafond de verre j'ai voulu savoir ce
que c'était que men mans de briser ce
plafond qu'est-ce qu'on laissait de sa
peau qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qu'on
nourrit c'est comme sentiment mauvais ou
bon d'ailleurs parce que mon livre et je
pense nuance et il n'est pas une
exaltation de ce mode-là de réussite il
en montre aussi tout le prix tous les
sacrifices
toutes les choses négatives aussi mais
je voulais savoir comment on fait quand
effectivement on a expliqué quand il
nous manque quelque chose pour parvenir
à ce à quoi on aspire comment on fait
l'ascenseur social on l'a vu il est il
est bloqué au sous sol l'escalier de
service maintenant est quand même le lui
aussi bien encombré faut souvent
escaladé la façade ccc ce livre tarifs
sur la volonté le système d et au final
j'essaie de comprendre ce que ça produit
sur la société parce que le mépris
fonctionne à double détente sert qu on
est méprisé on méprise à son tour et
j'ai voulu montrer aussi que le mépris
ne fonctionne pas seulement du haut vers
le bas que souvent le plus grand mépris
je les trouvais du haut vers le haut
c'est assez on aurait pu rajouter parmi
les réformes des manuels m'a conquis qui
voleront grâce à la réforme de l'ena par
exemple j'ai été frappée en interrogeant
par exemple jean pierre jouyet au dos
tres nac qu entre énarques en fonction
du classement fifa si on n'est pas
majeur des cinq premiers on se méprisent
royalement en fonction de sa place à une
autre équipe auxerre de valéry giscard
d'estaing c'est juste que j'ai
interrogés le dernier directeur de l'ena
qui me raccompagne après notre entretien
en m'expliquant que bon c'est exagéré de
dire qu'il ya du mépris pas renié
mécénat qui me montre la photo les
photos de toutes les promotions l'ena et
tombe sur la feue la fameuse photo la
promotion europe de valéry giscard
d'estaing il ne figure pas sur la photo
je demande pourquoi il dit mais parce
qu'il venait polytechnique
donc on avait accepté qu'à ce moment là
qu'ils aient dérogation y avait un ou
deux plats il a aidé à passer le
concours le même concours que les autres
et ça les autres écuries hier ne voulais
pas qu'il figure sur la photo
du mépris bruce sein même de l'élite
alors il ya un autre exemple laetitia
cru passer celui de l'écrivain edouard
louis ici il se vit comme un transfuge
de classe c'est ça oui il a dit ce matin
il était l'invité de la matinale de
france inter est en fait il a sorti un
nouveau livre qui s'appelle chang'e 2
points méthode il explique lui comment
il a réussi à passer d'un monde le monde
populaires ouvriers au monde bourgeois
il vraiment ils expliquent toutes les
étapes et lui sont un peu son gimmick si
vous voulez c'est sa ligne dans tout cas
de combat c'est que il faut inverser
l'échelle des valeurs et l'échelle des
étiquettes sociale écoutez
moi ce que j'ai appris de cette
trajectoire aussi sait à quel point le
la bourgeoisie et les classes dominantes
sont des classes assister voyez on dit
toujours des pauvres c d assister à
l'assistanat mais moi je peux vous dire
qu'en ayant vécu des deux côtés du monde
je vois à quel point la bourgeoisie et
assisté depuis la naissance tous les
privilèges le capital scolaire et qui
font que moi par exemple j'ai entendu le
mot classe prépa deux mois avant de
passer le bac il ya des gens dans des
milieux privilégiés qui savait déjà ce
que c'était qu'était déjà préparé à ça
et en fait quand on entre lecteurs de
transfuges comme ça on se rend compte
que dans les classes populaires si vous
voulez passer le bac il faut être
einstein et dans la grande bourgeoisie
suffit d'être un peu limité actu
intellectuellement il parle même d'une
transformation physique ça celui qui
avec s'est fait connaître en écrivant
une belle gueule oui en finir avec eddy
belle gueule qui est son vrai nom donc
il a changé de nom mais il n'a pas
changé que de nom il avait fait une
entrée fracassante en cd 2014 se livre
donc ça fait sept ans qu'il termine sa
transformation en changeant ses dents en
changeant ses cheveux ses vêtements son
accent et les mots il ne dit plus manger
midi déjeuner il dit voilà donc ils
expliquent vraiment étape après étape
comment ils rentrent dans la bourgeoisie
et finalement il y a accueilli et ce qui
est intéressant chez edwards lui c'est
que ce n'est pas uniquement un écrivain
c'est qu'il est aussi en ga et
politiquement d'ailleurs qu'il est
devenu une figure de proue du mouvement
de la gauche radicale qui met au centre
du débat la race le sexe le genre voyez
tous ces thématiques très moderne qui
vraiment colle à notre époque il en est
encore une fois une incarnation donc
c'est intéressant en tout cas le
parcours de cet écrivain là certains
disent qu'il est un très bon aussi
marketeurs d'édition c'est à dire que
ilan se creuse à sion et qu'il a trouvé
un bon sinon j'en sais rien en tout cas
il a le mérite de mettre sur la table
des thématiques qui sont d'actualité oui
et puis moi je retiens ce qu'il a dit
dans le
la partie de l'interview vous avez
sélectionné la bourgeoisie et les
classes dominantes classe assisté c'est
quand même c'est intéressant comme comme
affirmation oui c'est intéressant parce
que justement il veut retourner d'une
certaine manière le voilà l'image
d'assistanat qui collerait au milieu aux
classes défavorisées effectivement il a
raison on peut dire que tout converge
pour que les milieux favorisés
perpétuent leur avantage effectivement
d'une certaine manière avoir une famille
qui très vite se mobilisent sur
l'éducation qui a dû capital relationnel
qui a dû capitale économique où les
enfants ne voient pas leurs parents dans
des soucis financiers depuis leur plus
jeune âge c'est effectivement une
assistance fondamental c'est une assist
fondamental le thème le thème qu'il
traite est vraiment un terme intéressant
c'est pas seulement qu'il est une
personnalité intéressante mais le thème
qu'il traite est vraiment intéressant
cet instinct ressorts classiques aussi
la littérature qui est l'intrus où
l'intrusion la phrase l'effraction
pratiquement dans un milieu social il
voit tout à fait bellamy sas finit
souvent tragiquement d'ailleurs dans la
littérature parce que le
le personnage est rattrapé par
finalement son sens de son origine très
souvent mais c'est vrai que c'est un
thème qui est un thème qui a traversé la
culture littéraire française de longue
date je raconte ça aussi dans mon livre
a aussi ma métamorphose parce que j'ai
je raconte comment ça que je vois très
bien ce qui veut dire quand je suis
arrivée à paris je faisais pas forcément
tenir les couverts comme il fallait où
je disais effectivement manger les
résines et
provinces vraiment c'est à la gommer
mais là notamment dans les médias mais
je n'en ferai pas une lecture de classe
ce que je reproche à edouard louis ces
deux et il ya un certain déterminisme
maintenant ce qui est dit c'est à dire
que toute opinion devient une position
de classe je trouve se trouve réducteur
et là je trouve là qui a effectivement
un mauvais côtés aussi de ce
mois j'en fais aucune j'en tire aucune
gloire d'avoir sorti d'un milieu assez
modeste j'en fais pas non plus une
revendication politique mais c'est vrai
comme le dit olivier dussopt qu le
ministre des comptes publics interrogé
il dit c'est vrai
quand on quitte un milieu comme ça on
n'est plus tout à fait de ce milieu là
mais on n'est pas tout à fait reconnu
par le milieu qui nous accueille alors
les entreprises peuvent-elles sauvé la
france de son immobilisme
pour ça j'ai voulu trouver interrogé à
un chef d'entreprise s'appelle jérôme
miara c'est le pdg d'ovh est avec nous
en visioconférence société spécialisée
dans le conseil et rachetée dans le
domaine des politiques publiques en
matière de formation bonjour bienvenue
dans un sens public est ce que
l'immobilisme de la société française ça
parle particulièrement aux consultants
rh que vous êtes
ah oui tout à fait bonsoir bonsoir à
tous oui
l'immobilisme se traduit au niveau des
entreprises et gérer plus largement de
l'économie paris mobilité kiné qui n'est
pas assez forte pour rejoindre ce qu'est
ce qui a été dit par rapport à
l'ascension sociale on sait quand même
que la mobilité c'est le sait le
prennent premier vecteur d'ascension
sociale c'est ce qui permet de diffuser
les compétences d'explorer d'explorer de
nouveaux territoires et on voit bien que
aujourd'hui les transformations que je
sus que le cuivre les entreprises
ne permet pas forcément d'accroître
cette mobilité je donne un exemple sur
la la transition digital j'aimerais bien
que cette transition digital est en
train de détruire plutôt des emplois
dans les villes moyennes pour recréer
les emplois plus qualifiés
dans des dents des grandes métropoles
donc on est aujourd'hui dans une
situation finalement ou où l'urgence
compétences seul feu ça s'accélère on
connaît le classement de la france dans
l'est dans les grands indicateurs
internationaux relatifs à l'éducation
que ça soit pour les pour les collégiens
ou pour pour les actifs sains entre
entre 25 et 65 ans on voit que la france
décroche donc donc ça va dans le sens
d'une bonne mobilité maintenant comment
on fait je reprends la main j'en
reprends la manière de vous interpeller
d'ailleurs les candidats à la
présidentielle sur ce que vous appelez
l'urgence compétences mais je voudrais
reprendre on a on a beaucoup parlé d'
immobilisme est évidemment beaucoup
parler d'eux de mépris mais est ce que
finalement le monde de l'entreprise avec
son organisation qui est très souvent
pyramidale il ya quelques entreprises
pensent à un groupe comme décathlon qu'à
essayer de passer à une organisation
plus horizontale le de l'entreprise est
ce que c'est pas aussi et parfois
surtout le monde du mépris
alors je sais pas si c'est du mépris en
tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que les
inégalités qu'on peut trouver au niveau
de l'éducation l'éducation nationale on
les retrouve d'une certaine manière au
niveau de l'entreprise de manière
générale on voit par exemple que les
efforts de formation ont plutôt porté
sur les personnes déjà qualifiés déjà
même très qualifiés on voit que la
mobilité au sein de l'entreprise plutôt
d'un plutôt est destiné aux personnes
aux personnes qualifiées donc il ya un
véritable effort à faire vis-à-vis des
personnes qui ont des qualifications va
dire faire pour réussir à les hisser
dans ce système qui est un système
vertueux finalement ou où la compétence
permet justement d'accéder à cet
ascenseur social d'accéder à une
mobilité qui nous permet encore une fois
de de développer le lien est de
développer la qualité de vie au travail
et de pouvoir s'extirper de ses de ces
zones de ces zones un peu d'immobilisme
ça va c'est à la fois ça m'a servi j'ai
dit sauf pour les femmes encore beaucoup
même si les choses changent
on leur la compé la reconnaissance de la
compétence suffit pas pour accéder à des
postes à haute responsabilité elles sont
quand même sous représentées dans les
instances dirigeantes des entreprises
j'interroge d'ailleurs dans mon livre
une des très grandes chasseuse de têtes
qui de quitter qui chargeaient trouver
les patrons des groupes du cac 40 elle
cite cette phrase édifiante quant à la
ouvert son cabinet on le dit sauf votre
respect ne nous présentait pas de femmes
pour les postes élevés donc c'est ça
c'est pas pour quelle raison le mépris
concerne encore enfin les femmes je suis
très curieuse de connaître les raisons
elles aient raison alors ça c'était
l'époque où elle avait relégué à elle
elle raconte que ça a beaucoup évolué
mais encore aujourd'hui il ya un a
priori
en tout cas dans la direction les
entreprises où on estime qu'une femme
peut-être qu'elle sera moins disponible
qu'à la fin il ya toujours alors que
l'on voit que ce même scientifiquement
on peut prouver qu'une entreprise qui
fait la part belle aux femmes dans les
années où il ajouté et beaucoup plus
efficace et c'est ce que j'avais demandé
à jérôme ira pour conclure les
entreprises qui ont des femmes dans leur
commerce dans leurs instances
dirigeantes elles sont plus plus
efficace on l'a prouvé sa
gestion performante et puis je
rajouterais que aujourd'hui il ya des
dispositifs notamment de reaching
financier qui incite les entreprises qui
sont côté des entreprises cotées coté en
bourse a oeuvré pour l'égalité des
femmes parce que en étant bien notées
dans ces indices ça permet d'accéder à
des fronts il ya du capital donc il ya
un certain nombre de yassa un serment d'
éléments qui en faveur que ce soit par
la loi d'ailleurs puisque aujourd'hui au
niveau des conseils d'administration les
entreprises cotées sont tenus d'aller
vers l'égalité hommes femmes mais je
pense que aussi étonnant que cela puisse
paraître le monde sinon s'il va pousser
aussi les entreprises elles beaucoup
plus vertueuses en matière d'égalité si
jérôme miara le pdg de dauber aspect c
est donc dans le conseil rh annabelle
allouche le on parler d'égalité
d'inégalités le mérite il sert aussi ou
peut-être surtout à justifier les
inégalités absolument c'est même sa
fonction première c'est légitime et les
inégalités sociales les uns visibiliser
en quelque sorte et effectivement faire
en sorte que même ceux qui sont les
victimes en quelque sorte de la
méritocratie y croit tout de même et
tous les récits dont on a parlé et dit
belle gueule et c'est en fait finalement
contribuer à faire comme on y croit
encore et balaiera tout sébastien le fol
on est on est à la conclusion de ce de
ce débat les les solutions elles sont en
chacun de nous finalement oui j'aimerais
le croire mais je voudrais pas qu'on
conclut lecture de mon livre que le
mépris est une chance il il a plu left
rêvant tuellement pour quelques
personnalités
avec les personnels au contraire il faut
il faut sortir de cette spirale on
l'évoquait ça passe par beaucoup de
pistes à l'école mais il ya aussi une
vraie réflexion à avoir sur la place de
l'état la centralisation du pays le
droit du travail aussi y voyais on
parlait de l'entreprise l'euro les
entreprises en france les petites et
moyennes entreprises et parmi partie la
population aussi qui se sont quand même
assez méprisés il ya les pelles et les
chefs d'entre eux ces entreprises là
qu'ils estiment qu'alors qu'ils prennent
tous les risques qu'ils font tourner
l'économie on ne reconnaît pas le leur
mérite à juste titre merci beaucoup
sébastien le fol reste à ta place est
donc le titre de votre livre publié chez
albin michel en avait la louche juillet
merritt aux éditions anne à mozac merci
pour nos co 13 rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur au cnrs au cevipof
merci laetitia
jeudi c'est ça vous êtes là les mardis
et jeudis 2 mâles invités politiques
dorion nancy ni dans bonjour chez vous
c'est bien le titre de l'émission c'est
jean-baptiste lemoyne le secrétaire
d'état chargé du tourisme des français
de l'étranger et de la francophonie on
boit souvent brandir mon bic dans les
émissions c'est un type que j'ai donc ce
big est magnifique il était très green
et il m'a été prêté par la rédactrice en
chef de l'émission il avait le passé car
si isabelle j'espère que j'en aurai un
rouge demain on verra bien allez salut à
tous et à demain
[Musique]